instant. Mais d'abord on va
faire un retour sur cettejournée
collègue Yasmine.
Amerie Joe Garza, 10 ans
Uziyah Garcia, 10 ans, un garçon
génial et plein de vie,
disent ses proches.
Jose Flores Junior, 10 ans,
en 4e année, un amateur
de baseball, un grand
frère aimant, Eva Mireles,
44 ans, enseignante depuis
17 ans, tuée...
Lexi Rubio, 10 ans, avait
remporté un prix quelques heures
avant le drame.
Une distinction célébrée
en compagnie de ses parents
qui l'ont vue, pour la dernière
fois.
Le père de Lexi, est policier
- Des parents qui, à la fin
de l'année scolaire, devront
planifier des funérailles
de planifier
des vacances.
La petite ville de
16 000 habitants, pleure
ses enfants et leurs
enseignants.Eddy est venu porte,
mais il aimerait qu'il y ait
plus que des prières,
qu'on l'écoute enfin.
- J'espère mettre un peu
de pression pour changer les
lois, pour que ce type d'armes
ne se retrouve plus entre
les mains d'enfants et depersont
Pour le moment, le gouverneur
du Texas dit n'avoir aucune
indication que le tueur avait
un passé criminel ou de
délinquance ni qu'il souffrait
de troubles mentaux. Par contre,
il avait annoncé ses actes
sur Facebook.
Un discours qui ne passe pas
auprès de l'ancien représentant
du Texas, le démocrate
Beto O'rourke.
Le Maire de la ville l'invective
C'est à cause de malotrus c
vous, sortez!
C'est indécent de parler
de santé mentale alors qu'on
un jeune de 18 ans
à avoir un fusil AR15.
- Ceci est une ligne du lobby
pro arme à feu la santé mentale
n'est pas là , la question
est sur l'accessibilité
aux armes à feu.
- La légux États-Unis
sur le contrôle des armes à feu
est variable d'un état à l'autre
Francis Langlois
Membre de l'Observatoire sur les
États-Unis, Chaire Raoul
stion évidstion évidstion évidst
très polarisée à l'instar  des
élites politiques et le pdt
Biden a par exemple introduit
deux projets de loi pour retirer
de façon très modeste lecontrôc,
les deux projets de lois
sont bloqués au Sénat.
- La grande majorité des
américains, même ceux qui
possèdent une arme aimeraient
un meilleur encadrement.
D'autres continuent d'invoquer
le le 2eme amendement, introduit
au 18e siècle, par les pères
fondateurs pour se protéger
contre une armée
professionnelle... encore, pleut
leurs morts, à chaque tuerie
Ici YK RCMTL